[Applause]
foreign
get down
[Music]
abandon your voice
prepare for battle i do not fear death
well this is a thing i've heard of an
elf will go on the ground
where is war fear not
it's hopeless every orchid mordor's
gonna wear this rocket
maybe he does deserve to die
[Music]
the eagles are coming
authority is not given to you to deny
the return of the king
rule of steward is mine and no others
come have you come to a decision about
him now don't be hasty mr mediator
hasty but you must understand young
of it takes a long time
to say anything in all
[Music]
english
hey
[Music]
what are we waiting for
[Applause]
the ring cannot be destroyed gimli son
of gloin
by any craft that we here possess
the ring was made in the fires of mount
doom
only there can it be unmade
pass
[Music]
ah
yes
i should very much like
to hold it again
[Music]
you don't have any friends nobody likes
you
not last night i'm not listening all
right then keep your secrets
i know you have something to do with it
i was barely involved
all i did was give your uncle a little
nudge out of the door
whatever you did you've been officially
labeled a disturber of the peace
[Music]
you